Avery Kim: Today’s focus: security review prep.
Jordan Patel: Any blockers from last time?
Priya Singh: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on security review prep; start with a spike.
Samira López: Edge cases around auth and retries on security review prep.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on security review prep; parallelize testing.
Samira López: I think we split security review prep into two subtasks.
Samira López: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Avery Kim: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on security review prep.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on security review prep; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: Risk: data migration for security review prep.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for security review prep.
Avery Kim: Let’s capture action items clearly on security review prep.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for security review prep.
Noah Williams: From design side, We need to align with capacity.
Avery Kim: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on security review prep; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on security review prep; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on security review prep; start with a spike.
Noah Williams: Risk: accessibility gaps for security review prep.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, Design feedback is pending.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for security review prep.
Riley Chen: Risk: scope creep for security review prep.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Samira López: Infra-wise, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Samira López: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Samira López: Risk: flaky tests for security review prep.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on security review prep; start with a spike.
Avery Kim: Action: write migration.
Riley Chen: My take is we split security review prep into two subtasks.
Samira López: My take is we split security review prep into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Risk: accessibility gaps for security review prep.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on security review prep; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on security review prep; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: I think we split security review prep into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Risk: scope creep for security review prep.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for security review prep.
Jordan Patel: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on security review prep; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: I think we split security review prep into two subtasks.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for security review prep.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, Security review is likely.
Jordan Patel: Risk: accessibility gaps for security review prep.
Samira López: My take is we split security review prep into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on security review prep; parallelize testing.
Samira López: Okay, who can take ownership?
Priya Singh: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Avery Kim: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.